the jurgen experience
did you see nancy pelosi defend uh
insider trading he's just about to ask
what what'd you say i'm making i don't
know guys i'm doing great at it you guys
should try a bunch of people were
freaking out about it i think it was
crystal and sauger we're doing i didn't
watch it but i did see the headline
that she apparently oh it's incredible
you have to watch it it's like she's
just bypassing all the laws to make
hella cash she looks so guilty it's like
when uh they they tell robert durst that
they know that he did it and he like
starts burping and [ __ ]
just deflects you think about how much
money she's worth she she makes like how
much a year
how much does she make a year she just
funnels into her husband like no he made
the money not me technically
how much money does she make a year from
being a congresswoman or overall okay
stuff she's getting now or stuff she's
putting away somewhere where no one can
see it she's the speaker of the house
right oh you mean probably like a two
hundred thousand dollar job right she's
a big six hundred thousand just on
speaker the house money you're saying no
it keeps no i don't think it's that
money fauci is the highest paid
government employee and he's 223 223 and
fauci is slightly less than a half a
million dollars wow
jesus yes they got to make their money
on the side but fauci's like the highest
paid government employee i think fouchy
might even be
more than the president no i think the
president makes a little more than that
but presidents paid 400 grand
they got to start paying them more they
get better people yeah
they have like a 10 million dollar job
yeah but it is it's like an investment
if you get out you will have money for
speaking engagements yeah with all the
companies that you helped all the
companies that you like hey i like you i
like you you'll say god let's
they're like hey mike uh mike the former
president we'd love to have you come
speak at our conference and we're
willing to pay you a half a million
dollars so this is like weird bribes
yeah when but i'm in office right now
right after you get out it's not that
it's it's kind of genius it's a genius
con game what it is is like a virus
finds its way through the system and
they never tell on each other they're
left on the right side just like no no
we're all in that game yeah that's the
game of making big money after you quit
and then you can also sell books if
you're a president you write a book that
book is selling for sure do you remember
when the ufc paid eight and eight they
paid eight thousand dollars to lose a
fight another eight to win i think
there's still times like what is what is
the out don't what is the entry level
fight pay
can't still be eight eight it might be
10 and 10. but regardless these are like
winning fighters do you remember that
happened what did the fighters then do
did they accept just that salary right
or they went out and got it another way
that's what the [ __ ] congress is
doing they're just they're getting paid
well sort of except the congress people
in doing that they're they're playing a
game that's illegal to play yeah if
you're not like if if you know specific
that's how they put martha stewart away
isn't it wasn't it insider trading yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so what is insider
trading it's like you know something and
because you know something you can't
make a move on the market because you
have inside information is that exactly
what it is dude i told everybody yes
that's exactly right because you're on
the no so of course you would buy all
the stocks and rig the system is that
the most tempting
like illegal thing to do ever yeah
dude i said on my part if you [ __ ]
know something's about to happen yeah
let's hear what she says
she looks like a vampire
yeah she's always looked that way too
that's her what is that hold on
sorry
um
investigations finding that 49 members
of congress and 182 senior congressional
staffers have violated the stock act um
the insider training law i'm wondering
if you have any reaction to that and
secondly should members of congress and
their spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks
no to this second one pause pause pause
pause hold on you could tell when she
goes through a drinking i'm gonna be
talking for a while
right now i knew this is gonna come up
from a professional speaker who's
definitely hydrated enough for starters
shaking it's like right there like oh
boy okay let me hear this give me some
volume okay that's as loud as i can okay
go ahead
and the teeth and secondly should
members of congress and their spouses be
banned from trading individual stocks
while serving the congress no i don't
know to the second one um what any we
have a responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month review but
if
people aren't reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
we're a free market economy they should
be able to participate in that
she's telling why her husband should be
able to invest in stuff that she knows
about have you ever seen a person look
more nervous yeah it was the long sip
the gulp right afterwards and the
immediate shake go back to like minute
like second ten you as soon as he starts
she also licks her teeth before taking
the step
okay
i'm wondering if you have any reaction
to that and secondly should members of
congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving the congress no i don't know to
the second one um
any we have a responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month
review but if the people aren't
reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
she she already thinks what she's doing
is completely right she's like no we're
making this is how we make cash i don't
[ __ ] no way we're doing it i think
that's why she gave such a simplistic
answer she's giving this like very
simplistic almost vague answer
because should should you be allowed to
participate in the stock market when
you're influencing the direction of the
stock or when you know which direction
something's going to go in or when
you're going to pass a law that's going
to to benefit these businesses that's
going to force the stock to go up and
you know that so you invest a [ __ ] ton
of money before it happens that seems
like no one else is allowed to do that
that seems like it's a problem yeah that
seemed like now why is that not a
problem here's why they're [ __ ]
coaches
because i would also abuse it it's like
the coach so they're not you know of
course they would what i was saying
earlier it's like the most tempting
thing to do
you wouldn't do it the rest of us would
do it like we found out pete rose was
betting on and against his teams when he
was playing for the team that's sort of
the same thing well the against
foreign if you're betting on your team i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm like good you
should bet on your team